this is as good a time as any to remind
everybody that we never saw Donald
Trump's tax returns during the
presidential campaign we saw the tax
returns of every major party nominee for
the previous 40 or so years we saw
Hillary Clinton's tax returns during the
2016 campaign but we never saw Donald
Trump's and this is particularly
relevant in light of what happened this
week with Michael Cohen and Paul
Manafort the idea during the campaign
was that whatever is in the tax returns
is more damaging than the PR problem
Trump was having by not releasing them
and this is now as good a time as any to
revisit that because two of Donald
Trump's closest staffers were convicted
of tax fraud and campaign finance fraud
this week Paul Manafort and Michael
Cohen Amanda Terkel has a nice article
in Huffington Post about this she also
points out that trumps view on tax law
is likely very loose given the tweet he
sent about Paul Manafort which I'll
reread for you we had this tweet on
yesterday's show Trump tweeted after the
conviction of Paul manna for convictions
I feel very badly for Paul Manafort and
his wonderful family justice took a 12
year old tax case among other things
applied tremendous pressure on him and
unlike Michael Cohen he refused to break
so it's very clear from the sum total of
what Trump is tweeting there that
because the tax violations of Paul manna
for because they were 12 years old it's
just not really that serious to Donald
Trump so what we've got is number one
Trump really doesn't want us to see his
tax returns we knew that because of his
behavior during the campaign number two
Trump doesn't really consider tax crimes
from years ago to be legitimate crimes
in some way based on what he said about
Paul Manafort and number three and this
is the most important thing
multiple people surrounding Donald Trump
during the campaign committed tax and
finance related crimes if there was any
time where we would say wait a second
more than ever before it's time to see
those tax returns the time is now and
Trump's hesitation to show his taxes
could be the simple arrogance of not
wanting people to know that he's not as
rich as he claims he is that's been like
the most benign explanation we got
during the campaign
but when people around you start going
down for tax fraud including people who
you were regularly reimbursing for stuff
that wasn't always invoiced properly
sometimes as I told you yesterday the
the number 50,000 written on a piece of
paper because you owed michael cohen 50
grand for some miscellaneous tech
related campaign services everything is
pointing to irregularities in trumps own
taxes and his followers are defending
his decision not to release the tax
returns that's the sickest part of it I
was just thinking back to our younger
years are more naive days when we
thought that Trump wouldn't release his
tax returns because maybe he wasn't as
rich as he claimed to be yeah or that he
wasn't paying a very high tax rate now
that stuff seems to be old news it seems
to be a lot more serious than that and
the sick irony of it is that the guy who
claimed he'd be all about transparency
has somehow bamboozled his own
supporters into defending his opacity
with the taxes they say good for Trump
he's not gonna about a pressure from the
media to do something that he doesn't
legally have to do do you understand
you're part of the problem not the
solution if that's what you're saying
because he said when the audits are
finished I'll maybe release them and of
course the IRS explained that you can
release your taxes whether or not you're
under audit and time and again every
moment where it would have just been the
logical thing for any normal person to
say I'm gonna put the taxes out Trump
hasn't done it maybe when the audits are
done he'll finally release the taxes
maybe those are still ongoing
well Rachel Maddow did show us the front
page from his 1040 from 2005 yes so
you're not satisfied with just that well
it really didn't tell us very much
unfortunately but the lead-up the 25
minutes of lead-up was exciting if
nothing else listen we've got to see the
tax returns the guy is surrounded by
people who are getting convicted of
finance and tax related crimes it's
obvious that we've got to see those tax
returns and I implore the sane
right-wingers they do exist I've met a
couple of them in my day demand the tax
returns it's time to do it this episode
is sponsored in part by better help calm
slash Pakman which gives you access
to a fully licensed and experienced
psychologist or therapist through video
phone and text I know from the emails I
get that in our audience like in the
broader world there are people who are
struggling with different issues in
their lives and many of them choose not
to talk to somebody about it either for
financial reasons for reasons of stigma
associated with seeking out a therapist
and I think it's really important to do
everything you can to get past that
because it's really important to talk to
someone when you feel like that's the
right thing to do and what better help
calm provides is number one the
elimination of the stigma that could be
associated with it you work through
video phone whichever method is best for
you you also will be able to save money
compared to seeing an in-person
therapist and it is so easy to get
started that I encourage you to go to
better help calm slash Pakman a few
questions that you answer which will get
you paired up with a therapist that
meets your needs you can always switch
to somebody else if you don't feel as
though the match is a good fit and it is
something that everybody should have
access to go to better help calm slash
Pakman it's easy to sign up it's easy to
get started we've put a link in the
description if you're watching on
YouTube and once again that website is
better help calm /pa k ma n